hot breath that that is what i've heard
and you know i've almost done 200 of
these episodes
and a common probably the most common
theme is like
all most of your opportunities are going
to come from people you know
it's just it's it's friends it's friends
it's people that know you from something
that will give you something it's you
know that movie led to another movie
led to a play and and i was out of
comedy for
over a year and a half and you know
meanwhile patrice billy bird dane cook
bob marley gary gullman
we're all doing stand-up every night so
i was kind of left behind
a couple years and what brought you back
into it
everything was done you know the play
was done
i did the play uh like an off-broadway
play
and it didn't go went for a month or so
um and then i went back to comedy but i
i
you know when you're a comic it's like
when you get back up on stage but here's
the funny part
i went back and i was so far behind that
i couldn't get on
and people that i thought sucked were
ahead of me and i remember sitting there
going you know what this
i think i was talking to dane i was in
the back and i was like i'm out
this
this piece of shit's on right now i
gotta i'm sitting here
he's like dude just hang out you'll
you'll you know you'll get you just hang
you just gotta be here you just get a
hang and i'm like oh
and right then that's when noxie kevin
knox is one of the greatest comics ever
in boston who's passed away now he came
up because you wanna do five minutes i
was like yeah
and i went up and killed and from there
he would put me on every week
from that i started getting up over here
and then i started getting up now
okay he's legit and that's what young
we all want somebody to tell us we're
good enough
to keep doing it we all want some one
one of the guys to go you're good
[Music]
all it is is showing up all it is is
being there
and having the desire to be funny it's
all it is
getting on stage and being there that's
it
because if you're not there you're not
going to be there when they go you want
to go on
when they need somebody and if you're
not doing it all the time you're not
going to get better